Get ready with me while I'll tell you why you should be interested
about the European Parliament elections
that happened this year.
Being an European Union citizen gives you a lot of benefits.
Last summer I visited so many, uh,
European Union countries because as an European Union citizen,
I don't need visa, I have data roaming
and I have train connections to pretty much every country.
And I love travelling, so I really,
really love that opportunity.
And I am from Finland, but right now
I'm living in Poland for the spring and doing volunteer work.
And I have this opportunity thanks to European Union.
All these things related to European Union
is decided in the European Union Parliament.
And these are only a little examples.
There is so much benefits like privacy laws,
environmental laws, so many things that are decided in the EU
that affects every EU citizens life.
And did you know these makeup products I'm using
are also following the laws of European Union?
They check that all the ingredients are safe.
So if you want to have an effect on things that are decided in the EU
that affect your life, please go vote on June.
We will be telling you more reasons to vote on this TikTok account.
Thank you.